- So it seems at Zoom court
has struck once again.
Poor Judge Middleton,
who it seems has to deal
with all of the worst cases,
who dealt with the accuser,
who was in the same room as the accused,
with the person who was dealing
with a suspended license
while Zooming from a car,
is now dealing with this yahoo.
- Your name's not Butt
(beep) 3000 you yo ho!
- Yes, that is definitely
not his real name.
It seems that the judge
saw that the username
was something I can't say.
But, he was not amused.
The person who was making
the court appearance
clearly had no idea what was going on.
Seemed contrite.
- I don't believe that I
typed anything like that in.
- This is a misunderstanding.
Poor judge Middleton has
seen everything here.
He excoriates the person
for not checking your Zoom username.
Come on, we've been doing Zoom hearings
for over a year now.
You've gotta check your username
before you sign into court.
- Think about what you
call yourself online.
- And gave him a timeout to
think about what he's done.
So, I guess we'll see
this guy back in court.
- You yo ho!